that's like borderline snake
like that's like
that's like weasel dojicat calling out
stranger things star noah schnapp for
exposing her crush on his co-star joseph
quinn aka eddie munson this is for you
here's how it all started noah who plays
will buyers on the series shared
screenshots of his private dms with doja
on tick tock with the caption thirsty
dosia it's crazy
it went completely viral with over 20
million views but has since been deleted
the screenshots show dojo wasting no
time asking noah about joseph's
relationship status and noah ultimately
tells the singer to slide on over to his
co-star's dms herself
i don't know it's no secret the singer
has a little thing for the 29 year old
actor she's tweeted her feelings a few
times since watching stranger things
four and while she apparently enjoyed
the show's latest installment and
clearly eddie joining the mix she's
definitely not thrilled about her
private inquiry making its rounds on the
internet i'm just gonna say something
right now about the whole
the noah schnapp thing just hours after
noah's video went viral doja hopped on
tiktok to address the whole thing first
she gives noah the benefit of the death
since you know he's only 17 years old to
be fair this is like a kid
like noah is like i don't know how old
he is but like
when you're that young you make mistakes
you do dumb
i'm like trying to be super fair
you do dumb
you say dumb [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
up relationships with people you
you make mistakes you're supposed to do
stuff like that so that you know not to
do it in the future like i i did my
share of so that i don't again and after
explaining all that dosia ends her video
by slamming noah for violating her
privacy the fact that noah did that
like went and posted a private
conversation between me and him
is
so
unbelievably like socially unaware
and whack you know what i mean like
that's like borderline snake
like that's like
that's like weasel
and like
i'm not saying that encapsulates his
entire personality like noah is not like
the definition like i wouldn't imagine
yes maybe he is neither noah nor joseph
have publicly responded but joseph
hopefully he's feeling the love not just
from dozia but from stranger things fans
around the world this year it's my year
i can feel it
et spoke with the british actor earlier
this month he said the fan response has
been the ultimate form of flattery i
don't know it's kind of it's a
completely overwhelming feeling
it's it's so lovely like the
the devotion that the fans have for this
show and kind of
um how they've found space in their
heart for a new character
um eddie is just so it's heartwarming
and um yeah i don't know what to say
about it it's really they've been so
gracious and welcoming
it's lovely
[Applause]
you